Deus Ex mankind divided is on the way to
satisfy all your cravings for
stealth-action exploration and cool
augmentations but what exactly will you
be doing in the newest Deus Ex well
stick with me for a couple of minutes
and you'll find out Deus Ex is a
franchise dedicated to giving you a
whole lot of options for how you want to
conduct yourself in the game world and
engage with social and combat scenarios
in mankind is devided you'll find
yourself in a dystopian prague where
corrupt authorities are treating people
with cybernetic augmentations like less
of humans as you'd expect you'll
inevitably face off against various
gangs the Illuminati and rogue augmented
humans turn to terrorists if you prefer
to get up in her face you can unleash
bullets explosives nano blades and other
lethal orgs guns are moddable
ammo types are varied and you can equip
the new tough temporary titan shield
that coats your body in protected black
something which makes you invincible on
the other hand there's quite a few
options for those of you who prefer a
stealthy approach you're able to scan
rooms cloak to make yourself invisible
silently take down your foes lethally or
non-lethal a and hack terminals
environmental objects and security
systems that let you take control of
turrets and alter their friendly fire
and intruder tracking settings if you
prefer to keep your enemies alive you
can try it out your bullets for stun
guns tranquilizers all for your new
close range Tesla gun arm which deploys
Electrify homing projectiles to put down
your foes non-lethal a high dose
Montreal have said it is possible to
finish the game without killing anybody
bosses included the choices you make in
your interactions with NPCs will impact
the people around you and their
willingness to acquiesce to what you
want a lethal approach may adversely
affect your relationship with a pacifist
while your ability to get information
from allies may open up new
opportunities in how you can handle
future dilemmas you can gather details
about the world by talking to its
inhabitants and are using your skills of
persuasion exploring every nook and
cranny and accepting optional
side-quests from both friends and
strangers complications like traversing
a blockade can be managed by either
using force or exploring the environment
for an alternate less chaotic route you
can find new areas and plenty of loot
off the ground so clambering up
apartment buildings and looking behind
couch cushions is well worth the trouble
if clambering isn't your style another
one of your new augmentations is an
Icarus - which lets you get from one
spot to another instantly you'll want to
assess your environments and decide on
your favorite gameplay style early on to
sort out which weapons and orgs you want
on hand the world of Deus Ex mankind
divided is dangerous but lucky for you
Adam Jensen has the tools to handle it
let me know in the comments how you're
planning to play this one and stay tuned
for our review